so in an attempt to illustrate why it is
better to ask for someone's pronouns
rather than their sex or even their
gender
i'm going to make a comparison that i'm
hoping most parents will recognize and
appreciate
have you ever gone to mcdonald's when
the toy with a happy meal is one of two
things
and you order the happy meal for your
kid and they ask you well is it for a
boy or a girl well it would have been
much more helpful if they had just told
you
what the two toy options were so that
you could pick the most appropriate one
for your child
because they presume that if they know
if it's a boy or a girl then they
already know what that child would like
but
maybe your boy likes my little pony
maybe your girl likes transformers
given that in a practical day-to-day
communication sense it's ultimately
their pronouns that you actually
need asking them for their sex or even
their gender identity is you them
presuming oh because i know that i know
what you would like
but you don't know just like the people
at mcdonald's don't know what your boy
would like
and don't know what your girl would like
so since knowing somebody sex does not
necessarily mean that you know their
pronouns
just skip over the sex question in the
first place it doesn't matter their
pronouns do just ask that